and Facebook my name is Philip Todd I'm
the head of communication at dj''q Finn
thank you for joining us here today
we're very fortunate to have a number of
very distinguished speakers and we thank
them for joining us today and we also
would like to welcome the 25 students
from the University Board of Excel who
have also joined us many of them
probably don't remember life before the
Euro so it's going to be interesting to
hear their views as well before we get
started I just like to invite you to if
you haven't done so already please tweet
or post on Facebook about today's event
using the hashtag Euro 20 you may also
have noticed downstairs we have a
fabulous cake which will be cut up after
the coffee break so if you want to have
a photograph with the cake there's a
photo booth and please please take a
photograph in front of the front of the
backdrop and post it on Facebook or
Twitter so as we as we said get ready to
start I would just like to say a few
words of welcome to our first
distinguished speaker pepe Sarah Nene
the journalist author and scholar he is
going to speak to us on the topic of the
passion track and you'll hear more about
that shortly Pepe is currently the
editor-in-chief of Corriere della Sera
z-- weekly magazine 7 and a contributing
opinion writer for the New York Times
and what may be of interest to you is
that he was also voted to the European
journalist of the Year by European voice
in 2004 Peppa's career started off in
Brussels actually as a stager and dg5
then was or didi employment as it is
today and he enjoyed his time so much in
Brussels that he decided to swap his
planned career as a lawyer in a small
town in Italy for that of a
distinguished international journalist
so we're very pleased to have him here
today to give us a TED talk style
opening remarks please give a warm
welcome to our first speaker
Lepus opinion
good morning everyone it's such a long
way for a audience - yeah I'm so pleased
but this Monday morning is nine o'clock
and so it's not easy and I have to wake
you up and I'll give my i'll try my best
15 minutes started actually is 14 they
promised me 15 is already 14 because you
took a minute but it's okay
now today actually happy birthday won't
complain or everyone first of all that's
important to celebrate and I want you to
see you smiling but the whole point of
my speech is that celebration is a
celebration is not a and so often in
Europe we forget to celebrate our
achievement and we let the opponents of
Europe I won't use the word enemies
because there are no enemies in Europe
by the opponents of this idea of Europe
to celebrate whatever mistakes we all
make or failure or shortcomings I
celebrate passionately those we fairly
celebrate whatever we achieve that a
huge mistake which we're gonna pay very
dearly in a few months we have a few
months to correct it that's my opening
ok
actually I have two birthday today
because by a bizarre coincidence I have
a a blog which was born in on December
3rd 1998 so it's gonna be 20 today and
that's why I was voted European
journalist of the year it was not the
European voice but the readers of the
European voice and it's called Italians
and is the idea is bringing together
people around Europe and the world I
mean still going on of course is now
with the Socialists is getting old as I
am but as you all know on the internet
the 8th the ages and years are
calculated like dogs one equals seven so
my my blog which is actually older than
the actual word blog because blog the
word 1999 my blog 1998 turns a hundred
and forty so I'm quite pleased and proud
about this now I'm coming from Moscow
freezing cold and the other day I was
thinking of this speech and I was and I
was standing the Red Square but they
just opened they
skating ring and I was thinking what
holds these people together
the Russians together hey what is it is
it history is it the church is it the
president is it the borders and then
I've been many times to China I've been
reporting to China in crucial time all
the time and every time I ask myself
what is it that these they feel so much
you know they think they belong and I've
been writing and living in United States
and then the same question why I think
they will easily overcome this
presidency is because they think they
belong what about us Europeans what
holds us together let's see so I'm
personally very proud to be European I
I'm European Italian northern Italian
through Lombardi I work in Milano I come
from a small place called crema for me
Europe was a land of opportunity it is
true I was here s Teixeira that really
changed my mind my best friends are
still from that time actually I have a
degree in international law I was I
remember was the protection of
fundamental human rights in the European
community at the time it took me about a
week to realize that fundamental human
rights in European community were
basically alright and I had and so I
don't have to worry too much and I had
tremendous time for six months
travelling a meeting and learning about
Europe so he was great so for me um from
many of my generation Europe was the
land of opportunity my father passed
away two years ago it was almost a
hundred he was born in 1970 belonged 17
below it was one of the greatest
generation it was passionate European
and he told me is easy for me I was in
war it was a navy office in the War II
for the British first then the Americans
and the German and then his fellow
Italian the whole thing was crazy and
say now that you say I'm gonna see my
friends in Berlin or my see my friends
in Paris alone is such for his
generation it was easy I wonder if if we
by the way my father has this thing that
he believed passionately in the world in
Italian is solid Arietta solidarity and
he especially when it's getting old he
was writing everywhere I went have a
message he sent to me and my brother and
my sister it was like solidarity never
forgetting families my daughter's my
sons my nephew my niece is you have to
get along together it is the most
important thing and this solidarity is
in my mind I think I'll pass it on to my
Prime Minister Josep account and what is
going on in this last few days by the
way Commissioner Dombrowski's you have
in front of you the only Italian who's
not going to talk about budget deficits
so it's a little celebration for you two
we're gonna talk about something else so
for my father generation was easy for me
but what about our children and
grandchildren they may give Europe for
granted
Europe is comfortable we know that but
it's not enough no project can be just
comfortable the house Berg Empire was
extremely well organized and in a way
comfortable for Hungarians for Northern
Europeans were the people at the first
crisis collapse because there was no
passion and sense of belonging truly it
was like okay everybody does this bit is
not enough absolutely and I think we
must when I say we must be proud there
was an introduction it was absolutely
necessary when we say we must be proud
of this achievement the 20 years of the
Euro I mean we need passion where is it
I go around I travel all over Europe I
don't see that matter we have plenty of
reason to celebrate you look at the
video in on the Europe 28 you're a
twenty website I looked them all
yesterday in here and then at home it's
all there it's obvious 340 million use
people using the same currency is the
second reserve currency in the world the
second most traded currency he makes
we all know about it I feel almost
ridiculous repeated but we must not to
each other but to everybody we meet and
an argue with the people who tend to
forget what was the word before the euro
I wrote a story in the mid 90s I started
with two hundred thousand lira in Milan
I went around Europe and and I I
explained how all my money was wasted
just commissioned and changes and I got
back I did nothing at all but losing my
money travelling around Europe it was a
very pictorial way to explain what
happened this video should be on
national television these videos should
be broadcast before the evening news for
people that don't know Europe as much as
you do and I do they really need to hear
that in it and if any government in
Italy in Germany in oh oh anywhere will
say no we don't think it's well it's we
have a problem because this team since
the Europeans to everyone and everyone
and it's 340 million people each country
should contribute and these videos it's
a message we have to get through to most
people as possible look at this video
and see how how well how well they work
the currency is powerful and is
emotional a friend of mine he's he's
works for the Commission in in Brussels
I've known him for some time he was
telling me that his daughter 21 the
other day she was in Budapest
she put up she put her card in the cash
machine and she took away and she looked
at the money and she didn't know what
they were and they she called to say I
thought it was euro and it's not your
and I father explained well hungry
doesn't help the euro they have a
different currency and she had a great
remark you say but they have roaming why
they don't have the Euro that it's
perfectly logical for someone roaming
and the euro currency and talking to
each other free
and cheaply at last its is things that
touch is the sort of things that touch
everyone the when I decided to call this
little speed introduction speed the
passion trap the idea is this is simple
and I keep returning on it
we don't put enough passion into this
the passion is simply not there forgive
me for being blunt but I think that to
enflame passion about the euro
explaining to the broader old trick to
to to the the general public the
importance of the European financial
stability facility as important as it is
it's like to try to rekindle the sex
drive of a middle-aged man reading to
him the leaflet on a box of
contraceptives you can try but it's very
hard Europeans know that the euro world
the Euro works the latest figure have
you seen it but let me repeat some of
those 74% the latest poll the Europeans
savers they they EU and the Euro 64
percent think of the Europeans using the
Euro think yer is good for the country
sixty percent of the Greeks 57 percent
of the Italian and that percentage went
up were talking about this just now
twelve percent in the last year which is
which is extremely impressive
of course close the fiscal cooperation
is needed we all know about that
of course we made mistake can I mention
just one that really touched a lot of
people especially in my of my country
Italy the stealth inflation at the
beginning the fact that that the change
between the lira and the euro was not
monitored properly and some prices went
up the shut up and people was fixed
income the really did have a problem and
built an animosity towards the Europe
that still hasn't gone away that was a
mistake but but obviously this is work
in progress in 20 years this was a
tremendous achievement let's not forget
that we should not shout because we're
not the shout in kind of people but so
often on Italian television I had the
chance to talk to two people some of
them are in my government now who bet
with claim the euro was that the root of
the problem of Italian economy and I
said no stop blaming it's too easy
blaming the Europe lemming the year they
you and even worse when people and the
government who believe the euro and the
European Union is a good thing I had
when I was mentioned it was four
different Italian Prime Minister there
were parties and people that were in
favor of the euro at the European Union
but he was too tempting to blame the
European Union for your shortcomings
that's another mistakes and someone
should go on television calmly on
newspaper on the social saying stop
doing this you cannot do this and
pretend that nothing happened you won't
have consequences look what happened I
mean it the referendum the practice
referendum I was there I know Charles is
here and I'm sure the British people is
here what happened is simple the people
who believed to leave these not currency
this is European Union the people who'd
passion in what they were doing that in
brexit they won the case the people who
believed that staying in Europe I didn't
say standing European staying in the
European Union's great they say after
all is the you know the lesser evil
that's not the way you win your case and
they're the same with the Europe so my
proposal is this you all know of course
they may ninth is Europe lay day right
I've stopped asking when is Europe day
when I speak around Europe because I'm
disappointing when too many people don't
know that May 9th is Europe day and I
will not ask why May 9th is Europe day
in this room today I know I'm also
Trichet many others will know the answer
perfectly but some other want so I want
us but I remember two or three years ago
here in Brussels I proposed this is to
lukewarm to
is I may not make May 9th no Europe day
let's make January 1st 1999 or maybe the
introduction of notes and coins so in
2022 their anniversary let's make it
know Europe no Euro day for one day of
course he's not be possible but the fact
of announce you'll see just think about
it for one day we all go back to our old
ways you'll have 340 million people
going mad and that exactly what we need
only when you take away or just the idea
of taking away something from someone he
or she will understand what is gonna
miss the euro is like the European Union
sometimes given for granted is not
that's why I was so proud when you asked
me to be here and I just want to kick
off with this with you if we don't put
passion we're gonna lose with people
that put passion passion is two
pressures believe me to leave it to the
unreasonable thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the first
discussion we're gonna have today the
first the first panel is about the years
journey so far so first let's invite our
speakers we have jean-claude Trichet of
the former president of the European
Central Bank you can come up Valdez
dumped rox.kis the European Commission
vice-president for the euro Daniel Nui
the head of a single supervisory
mechanism and Charles Grant the director
for the center of year for European
reform today's yeah today's discussion
our first discussion is about the path
of the euro the 20-year so far it needs
very little introduction it's been a
pretty remarkable journey for for most
of us in here anyway and it's it's in
highs and it's in lows I mean as we as
we heard now it's the hero is still very
popular among member states it's seen
prosperity and convergence but also
really painful financial crisis and me
personally I'm Greek so it's definitely
had a very profound impact on my country
where people are still very largely
pro-pro euro which is really important
and the journey isn't over it's so
evolving already later today finance
ministers are meeting to discuss how to
strengthen the common currency there is
there's no consensus when everything yet
but there's still there's definitely an
agreement that the architecture should
be improved so it could better withstand
crisis in the future which may not even
be that far from now but the second
panel is gonna address the future more
although I'm sure we're going to touch
upon lessons learned and how we can
improve the common currency but for now
maybe I'd like to start with Charles
Grant and a question of the origins of
the euro because you you've looked at
closely and written about it and I guess
the first question I wanted to ask you
was about I mean you've written that
biography on the law you've looked at
his role very closely I just wanted to
ask you how important his personal
contribution to this was into getting
the Euro of the ground into you know
getting through the resistance and the
skepticism and more broadly about the
start of the year I mean
was it in your view more of a political
or an economic project sure but I think
the law played a huge role a lot of
people were talking about EMU or
something like it in the late 1980s the
timing was right the single market had
been a great success there was a quite a
lot of economic growth you had a lot of
very experienced leaders around Europe
who knew each other and trusted each
other and law sorted out the so-called
pack ADA law the budget settlement in
1988 and he was very clever at
exploiting opportunities he was a great
opportunity I think in the good sense of
the word he saw that now was the time to
push forward towards a monetary union
but I'd say a crucial role was played by
tomorrow Paderewski oper the great
italian economist who came to cede to
law in 1986 and said to him look in your
single market program your liberalizing
capital movements that will destabilize
the exchange rate mechanism of the
European monetary system and he
periscope and then wrote a report for
the law that the report of 1987 which
was quite important to basically there
was a trilemma Paderewski upper said you
can't have at the same time a stable
exchange rate mechanism free movements
of capital a national autonomy on
monetary policy something would have to
give so he really had to move forward or
move perhaps risk losing the ERM or move
forward towards monetary union so I
think that was an economic in a way
driver for monetary and many people
certainly anglo-saxon world believe that
it was a purely political project it was
all about a deal between France and
Germany you know Germany got unification
and in return it gave up the deutsche
mark there was an element of that but
let's not forget that the Madrid summit
of 1989 basically endorsed that the
conclusions the de loire report on
building a monetary union and that was
before long before anybody thought the
German wall would come down so I would
say it wasn't just about German
unification just briefly on under
Laurent himself and he was the guy who
helped persuade Helmut Kohl to adopt the
Euro against obviously a lot of German
public opinion in 1988 Helmut Kohl
appointed the law to chair the de loire
committee at the Hannover summit in June
1988 and a law handle that commits
very well a lot of technocratic work was
done it wasn't a political committee the
law cleverly got the central bank
governors on board to come up with
technocratic solutions including
including Colorado pearl he didn't like
the Euro at all but kind of went along
as he felt he had to as the leader of
the Bundesbank
so I think the law was very very clever
at handling that and and unlike the
political union side of the Maastricht
Treaty which dolor lost control of and
handled rather badly and was never happy
with the result I think he was fairly
happy with the with the with the EMU
side of it I mean he knew that if there
was going to be monetary union then it
had to be more or less on German lines
and the result was a compromise that the
law report was somewhat modified in the
Maastricht Treaty but it went through so
I'd I'd say to conclude that they'd
lured that the movement to monarch unit
was partly economic as well as political
but de lor was very very clever at
getting everybody to work good and
exploiting the opportunities which he
saw at the time do you feel that this
kind of balance I guess no balance but
the it being more of economical and
political perhaps in the beginning has
this changed over the years given where
we stand now or do you think it's still
primarily more importantly an economic
Union well I think you know with
hindsight
there should have been a bit more
thought about the economics I mean I'm a
big supporter of the euro I failed to
persuade the British people to join the
euro in the late 1990s but I do think as
we've learnt and the World Cup apps
coming to the slope we learnt in in
recent years there were there were some
design flaws is it still a work in
progress you know there was no banking
union in the original idea there was no
lender of last resort there was no
mechanism for enforcing governments to
engage in structural reform we probably
let in too many countries too soon and
there was no counter cyclical there was
no mechanism for the Chilean
counter-cyclical fiscal policy the
trouble is the people who criticized the
euro who attacked it at the time it was
being conceived and dreamed up they were
rather nasty people they were kind of
mad British and American euro skeptics
who we didn't tend very seriously I mean
that the Bundesbank of course didn't
really believe in the Euro at that time
but kept on saying it won't work without
a political union they may have been in
some respects right but they said that
to try and stop the project Knox they
really wanted to political union we're
gonna get to the design flaws I think
later in a goblet before that maybe vice
president I just wanted to turn to you
you were the prime minister of Latvia
when the country joined the euro
I was just wondering based on your
experience looking at it from the
outside first as a Member State wanting
to join how important was it for you and
for your country to join the common
currency to join the euro both
politically and economically and I guess
maybe in hindsight because now in your
current role you deal a lot with
countries that want to join the euro so
later on in a few years times perhaps
what kind of advice would you have to
give to them as from the lessons learned
so far well first of all I would like to
say that from our part of the world
sinks looked more obvious because when
we alongside was nine other countries
were joining the EU in 2004 say you was
as a euro was already there and actually
all new member states joining the EU
also committed to join the euro area so
what we were doing we were basically
implementing on
of course there were lots of debates is
it a good idea to join the euro area
because as it happened so those debates
took place still during the eurozone
crisis so we had most of the discussions
should we join the euro area not in 2012
and it was still a eurozone crisis so it
took lots of work also to explain that
we're talking here about crisis in
certain eurozone member states and not
euro crisis as such and by the way like
we had went through very difficult
financial and economical crisis between
2008 and 2010 without being in eurozone
so you know if you miss manage your
economy you end up in a crisis
regardless if you are in eurozone or if
you are outside the eurozone and then
from from the government point of view
so it primarily as an economic issue so
there were a lot of discussions also
political angles but I kept emphasizing
joining the euro is primarily economic
issue so the question you need to
respond this does joining the euro area
is facilitating economic development in
Latvia or not and if the answer it is
then the answer is that it's also good
idea to join eurozone and by setting
this goal already in 2010 early 2010
during the crisis it also provided some
kind of a policy anchor so we knew what
we need to do in terms of fiscal policy
what we do need to do in terms of
structural reforms to actually be able
to join so it's helped also as a per
policy anchor and it must be said at the
end of the day it has been very
successful despite difficult discussions
now a clear majority of lateral supports
latter being in eurozone and also we see
that the benefits for economic growth
tangible benefits
are actually materializing so indeed
it's helping with economic development
and being the vice-president for the
euro and Yale we're seeing these
discussions about accession but also
have been witnessed at least the last
part of the crisis in 2015 from your
position what what do you think is
important to keep in mind and to when we
discuss other countries joining the
currency in the following years well I
would say we need to discuss I would say
it from the most angles we need to
discuss deepening economic and monetary
union and many of the things which were
just outlined as a flow so original
flows and in design of euro area
actually had been corrected through
after the crisis we know how European
semester to more tightly coordinated
fiscal and fiscal and macroeconomic
policies of member states we have
european stability mechanism to help
euro area countries in difficulty we
have a banking Union European Central
Bank has expanded its monetary policy
tools including so-called outright
monetary transactions that was Mario
Draghi was referring in his famous
whatever it takes so many of the things
had been done but the work is not
completed we still need to put in place
remaining elements of the banking Union
including the backstop for single
resolution fund progress towards
European Deposit Insurance Scheme we
still need to complement some of the
fiscal instruments in a euro zone
including Commission's proposal on
reform support program to facilitate
structural reforms in member states and
fiscal stabilization which we propose in
a form of European Investment
stabilization and function all those
proposals are on a table actually later
today we are going to have a euro group
dedicated Europe to discuss exactly
those issues later this month we have
euro summit and European summit and we
hope that we'll be able to make real
progress also on those outstanding
issues
then if we talk about eurozone
enlargement I think that's a positive
thing that eurozone remains open and
attractive to new member states and we
know that right now several countries
are working towards this Bulgaria has
already came forward is a clear list of
commitments to implement to join
exchange rate mechanism to as a step
towards euro we soon expect Croatia
following the suit and probably one of
the lessons from the crisis was that
it's not only enough to tick the boxes
to take the nominal mastery criteria
that also you need a structure of the
Member States economy which allows it to
be successful once inside a euro zone so
that's why we have now more emphasis
also on this real convergence on the
economic structures and member states
joining and the novelty is that now
joining the eurozone also means joining
the banking Union it means more emphasis
on what's going on in a banking sector
of those member states but as a general
from European Commission side we are
supportive to those member states which
are willing to join your area not only
like granting the political support but
we also proposed a dedicated convergence
facility providing technical and in some
cases also financial support for those
member states actually to to prepare
themselves for joining zero right and I
mean we'll discuss more the banking
Union later on today and all the
structures that you mentioned that were
kind of put in place to improve the
resilience of the currency but first I
want to go back a bit because this is
again about the past I want to go back a
bit to the to the beginning of the euro
crisis and maybe turn to mr. Trichet who
was at the home of the ECB during that
time I was just wondering if you could
talk to us a bit about your personal
experience being at the helm of the bank
then what was it like for you I mean did
you get a sense that the euro was was
ready for something of that size and
scope did you expect it and how was it
to be there at that time
first of all I would echo what was just
said in the very elegant first speech
that we had namely euro is a big big
success a big historic success we
promise to deliver a currency which
would be at least as good as the best
currencies as the national currencies in
Europe we deliver that we deliver the
credible currency which inspire
confidence and that is now fully
recognized second we deliver the
currency which is which was practically
overnight the second major currency in
the world far far far over and above the
third currency which is what was the yen
still is third we had a currency which
is back back the people of Europe that
was said the figures are absolutely
striking and had we not been back by the
people of Europe we would not have been
resilient in the crisis we were 15
countries at the moment of the Lehman
Brothers bankruptcy I experienced that
very moment the 15 are still there and
four new countries got in including
Latvia so that we are 19 today and it's
not achieved as said the Vice President
so it's very very impressive to see to
which extent this idea that the euro is
fragile the euro area is fragile the
crisis will destroy and dismantle the
euro area was plain wrong
we had the stress test we passed the
stress test 19 countries today and more
likely to come now I experienced the
crisis in three episodes first episode
the subprime crisis it was only seven
and seven and a half years after the
start from scratch of you the first
episode of a dramatic crisis born in the
u.s. in Wall Street we decided the 9th
of August 2007 together my friends of
the ECB Governing Council my friends of
the ECB Executive Board to deliver
liquidity as much as was necessary in
Europe we were asked a 9th of August
2007
9
see five billion euros we delivered 95
billion euros and we kept our own money
market I would say as well as possible
in these dramatic circumstances then one
year afterwards approximately we had the
15 of September 2008 collapse of Lehman
Brothers the worst crisis since World
War two in New York and the worst crisis
perhaps since World War one
had we not been extremely Swift and bold
in our reaction I'm speaking of the
central bank on the front line and then
of the government as far as we were
concerned we generalized the full
allotment at fixed rate in order to have
liquidity to all our commercial banks as
much as they wanted in order to be sure
that our economy would continue to
function and we embarked in very bold
measures like LTRO long-term refinancing
operations and also purchases of
tradable securities and it was the
second dramatic with the episode fancy
in the US they could not avoid the
collapse of Lehman Brothers they were
rejected by the Congress of the United
States when they presented the top
program which was refused as you
remember even after the Lehman Brothers
bankruptcy in Europe we had 15
governments as I explained and 15
decision-making process to get the
decisions in order to avoid any systemic
bankruptcy in Europe we avoided it the
probability of having a new Lehman
brother was very high because you needed
in terms of probability to go through 15
decision-making process it's absolutely
remarkable that we could resist that
period I have myself a memory of going
in Brussels to explain to the Belgian
government why it was absolutely
necessary to save 40s for instance and
and and with many many governments in
Europe then we had the start of the
sovereign risk crisis which I
experienced
in 2010 and 2011 and again we took very
very bold decisions practically
overnight I would say at least in a
weekend I decided with my colleagues to
purchase greek securities Irish
securities and Portugal securities in
May 10 and that was of course something
which was considered so bold that all
the editorial were against in some
countries we're against the decision we
took and of course we avoided the
explosion of speculative crisis that
would have been totally dramatic and we
did the same in 11 in August 11 Spain
and Italy were attacked by speculation
and again in a weekend we decided to
purchase massively Treasuries of Spain
and Italy at that time I would say that
37% perhaps of the GDP of the euro area
was under attack and we resisted this
very very violent attack and of course
we saved the you were here at the same
time and then it went on because in 12
we had new I would say challenges the
vice president referred to and it was my
successor because I passed the baton as
you know in November 11 so we passed the
test of the worst financial crisis since
World War two I would insist on that I
will stress that point because it makes
me extremely confident but the last
point and conclude on that when I look
at growth per capita in the euro area
since the setting up of the Yahoo I see
the same level of growth per capita that
I see in the United States of America
that this idea that maybe we were
resistant maybe we resisted to the
dramatic stress maybe we are backed by
the people but it goes without saying
that we have a failure in terms of
economics Hale economy I think it's
wrong
and I don't mean of course that we are
in the best of the world possible we
have a lot of hard work to do and the
first to call for a Minister of Finance
of the euro area the first to call for
more democratic accountability in the
euro area but again and I echo what you
said sir let's not be ourselves
intoxicated by the negatives
communication I praise the Commission
for embarking on a very positive
communication on the Euro it fully
deserves it not to be negative I mean
you mention all these extraordinary
measures that you took and no one's
doubting that but I'm just wondering if
at any point you thought we should have
thought through more carefully what to
do in case a crisis of this scale hates
I mean are you in hindsight is there
anything else you could have done
differently you thing or given the
political limitations at the time this
was the best response I could have could
have happened first of all the same
question of course is asked to the US
Fed never it started in the United
States so I take it that we were all
unaware of the kind of weakness which we
are building up in in the economic
economies of the advanced country so
that that's clear and a lot of lessons
have to be drawn from that it is the
work of the g20 of the commercial
Stability Board and of all I was
responsible institutions in the world to
work on that very very actively
including of course the Commission
second point I have to say that as far
as Europe is concerned we had all the
problems of the Federal Reserve if I may
and the Commission had all the problem
of the executive branch in the US
together with the council but on top of
that we have a historical or historic
endeavor so we we have a double
challenge being one of the most of the
two most important integrated economies
in the world in the advanced world but
also having incredibly bold goals as big
as history and it seems to me that of
course we were not fully prepared the
proof of that is what the vast presence
to two new treaties want to create the
fiscal compact another one to create the
European Stability Mechanism the
invention of the MIP macroeconomic
imbalance procedure which is a fantastic
new pillar which did not existed before
banking union and of course all this has
been created in the crisis by on the
proposal of the commission by the
council with again a lot of negotiation
difficult negotiation but we proved that
Easter is in the making in the crisis we
could range force formidably yeah but we
have a lot to do still of course goes
without saying the u.s. single market
with a single currency was not done in
10 years or 20 years it was done over
time and we have to judge what we are
doing over an asterick time it started
long before it started in say 50 with
the speech of virtue man inspired by
Germany and the right question is where
will we be in 68 new years of the
European construction not only do of
course but the open construction no I'm
glad you mentioned the fiscal compact
and the yes I mean all these things
because I want to get to them shortly
but first I wanted to get to the banking
union a bit and stay on you II as well I
mean this is arguably the most important
thing that came up with the crisis to
safeguard the financial sector and you
were the the first person at the home of
the SSM one of the two pillars I was
just wondering if you could tell us what
was it like first of all your personal
experience being there doing the first
stress tests what was it like for you to
lead this institution but also how
important do you think the banking Union
was in is to to the euro survival well
let me start by reacting to the request
for patient for Europe I am personally a
passionate European and I think we
should never forget that after two
terrible wars we were killing each other
by millions before Europe and in my view
already peace is enough to stay
passionate I had nothing to do with the
creation of the euro because I was not
even in bang the force I was in the bath
oil in the B is working for supervision
that's all committee secretary ax but I
was following the developments with
patient first of all because be is is
also home for central bankers on the law
committee met also in the in the BIS
that cannot be forgotten and I was
following in the well research pieces
research work all newspapers the
developments of the Yahoo and I was I
guess like the British citizens living
on working outside of the UK right now
following the development of the brexit
negotiations when you live abroad you
want to know what your country will look
like when you are back and I was quite
anxious because about the success of
this project because for me was indeed a
very very inspiring project and I was
very sorry not to be part of it I could
not have been more far away because I
never did monetary policy I was not even
in the close to the notes making but
still it was as a citizen very very
inspiring
well regarding the banking Union while I
started learning about it well it was a
dream coming true coming true because my
patient for Johan my professional
capacity was being joined together to
prepare this banking union but I was a
little bit anxious as well because I had
considered applying for a bar but I
discovered that I was six months too old
for a bar to apply you what to be able
to have a full mandate
I think in mind that the age for
retirement in Europe was 65 when I was
60 on a horse
so don't finish so my personal fate was
depending on the speed of the work of
the legislature to create the SSM and
also note age limit for applying so well
I was keeping my finger crossed well it
went to no age limit extremely fast
incredibly fast though based on the time
it takes to take legislation in your
heart that's normal we are 19 countries
and well we started as powerful startup
in a very tiny startup in a powerful
incubator it was quite special moment I
left the French a CPR when I was leading
a team of 1,100 people banking and
insurance supervision and I moved to
Frankfurt on 2 January 2014 I had two
assistants one concealer on the
secretary of the Supervisory Board we
you see single end was enough to count
us and I was ah stood in a Japan tower
which could have been a nice place for a
movie because all the desk quad-a but
the people wanted there we were and full
of people floors with that's the beauty
of a powerful incubator in a very small
period of time everything was there
waiting waiting for us and it took
months to have the DG's the for first
DG's on for 10 people for TGS on their
deputies we had almost 400 candidates so
we were able to really get the the the
best of the European supervisors the the
only request was to have European
passport we had 28 countries represented
and we knew that we had first of all no
home for her for sure because it was
coming I don't know whether I should say
in the end or in the middle of terrible
crises and we had to take over normally
by November so 10 months legislators had
committed to extend this period of time
by six months if needed but it was not
possible in our mind we could not be
late we we had to be fully ready on
during the first months then first
months we were recruiting at light speed
almost signs to the capacity of the ECB
to process those things when people were
entering into the SSM on Monday arriving
we were telling them that well chew on
Tuesday morning they will start the
recruitment of their deputies in the
panel that will be in room X or Y you
see that was really wet process and we
had we recruited 1,000 people before
November with no support services and we
had to do this comprehensive assessment
health check for 130 banking hoops
comprised of 1200 bags that we would
provide the following November banks
that we did not know on working together
with people in the national computer so
it is that we were not accustomed to
work with so very very challenging but
also passionate exercise we knew that we
had to do it well because afterwards we
will suffice these banks we learn our to
supervise these banks and we were really
very very proud of ourselves in November
when we were able to take over
being in reasonably good shape having
the outcome of design check on thoughts
for supervisory action obviously after
this exercise I was speech pronounced on
on that day and I was very hungry
promising to my staff that ok we had
done the most complicated part do so
much working so hard for tens months and
after that should be a little bit more
confortable it was not more confortable
we had a lot of things to fix we had to
well it was largely prepared before
November but a new manual and we took
the best supervisory practices wherever
they were especially in Europe but even
beyond your heart on that ad the beauty
of being a very good team building
exercise because nobody had everything
hide we all had something that we could
improve so that was the objective make
the bank safer on Sunday as fast as
possible and and back everybody in this
exercise by picking up the best banking
practices best supervisory practices
wherever they were obviously we were
helped as well by the legislators after
a crisis legislators forget about the
regulation they are happy to regulate a
bit more I hope it will go on I am not
so sure I feel the regulation mood
sometimes in the current current time
and I mean all the set up and everything
that you achieve so quickly how much of
a game changer do you think the banking
Union the two pillars anyway that we
seen so far was for the Euro and how
important is it with the discussions
ongoing now and it is on the third like
how important do you think this is to to
happen and to happen quickly well I
think it has been a significant game
changer and I have not met yet anybody
saying that it was not true
we have really made
safe on Sunday I am NOT saying that we
are where we would like to be for sure
on in fact supervisors don't like too
much to celebrate soundness of banks I
would prefer to consolidate not
celebrate our achievements but but still
I think we have made it clear that banks
are safe and sound I will take one
example non-performing exposure we
started with one trillion of
non-performing exposures in the balance
sheet of the the banks from the 19
countries the significant institutions
of the 19 countries this is absolutely
scary now we are around 600 40 50 years
but it's getting down almost every day
and we have put in place the tools that
were needed for that under the
qualitative tools the quantitative tools
at the beginning for the flows on an
hour also for the start we also had to
work out on should not have been the
case really to harmonize the legal
framework we need more regulations that
directly applicable and not transpose
into 19 different legal frameworks not
very consistently to be honest we had
also 162 national options you know
framework we managed to address the ones
that were in the ends of national
competent authority because we were the
new national competent authority for the
euro area it we decided to have them of
course implemented in the in the same
fashion well it was not always obvious
but we managed to do it we still have 40
such options which are in the ends of
legislators on that we can we cannot
change on that that's a pity this being
said I think we have reached the point
where risk
decrease enough to start the journey
towards eddie's
we are discussing the value of the euro
but what we would like also is to have
Yoho deposited in a bank in French
German Finnish Spanish Italian bank to
be value by citizens the same it will
not be the case until we have a single
Deposit Guarantee Scheme I think we have
to move in this direction the banks
supervise at European level they are
resolved at the European level for
example Banco Popular was case in point
because the bank was supervised by us it
was resolved by the single resolution
mechanism but if there was no acquire
for Banco Popular the Portuguese Deposit
Guarantee Scheme for example would have
been the one reimbursing the depositors
in in Portugal that that's not that's
not correct so I think we we have
decreased risk significantly enough to
start the journey towards it is that's
the height moment we have for me we have
decided during the crisis very fast with
a lot of commitment to cross a river we
have left the side of the river with
national supervision national regulation
but now we are in the middle of the
river we are we have to go to the other
side we cannot stay in the middle of the
river that's not the best place to be
when there is a storm and there will be
another crisis for sure we don't know
when we don't know what will trigger it
but there will be another one which
would be safe on the other side of the
river and I guess I'll ask one last
question before switching to the
audience maybe mrs. Bechet to you on
this crossing the river I mean you
mentioned the assembly fiscal compact
all these things that happened very
quickly from leaders who struggle to
agree often on these issues why do you
think it was that they could agree so
quickly then but now you know a lot of
people would say they're dragging their
feet on these key issues like completing
the banking union I mean what what could
happen now to push them
this is nuit is alluding to one of this
strategic decision already
but not fully implemented and I know the
Commission is working very very hard to
get the full implementation I would say
the same perhaps a little bit for the
macroeconomic imbalance procedure for me
it is a fundamental pillar of governance
in the euro area and we are still at the
beginning of the implementation of the
symmetric implementation if I may of the
macroeconomic imbalances issue so a lot
of things remain to be achieved that
have been already decided in the crisis
and rightly so obviously still of course
when you are in the crisis you have a
lot of energy you have a swirl in the
back and you have to deliver because you
have to surmount the drama it's true at
global level with the London summit of
the g20 which was externally productive
and now of course the g20 summits
obviously are much less productive it's
not surprising it's human nature still
of course we have to be as I would say
lucid as possible as it was said we will
have a next crisis it will be also very
demanding and let's prepare in the best
fashion possible to the next crisis it
is also in the making we will see what
happens but we need some kind of budget
for you we're here as I already said I
told that we need to improve very much
the euro area functioning also on the
governance issue perhaps and on the
democratic accountability issue those
things will be done I'm sure that it
will be done but of course we are all
thinking that we should accelerate
because there is a sense of urgency at
global level as well as at European
level so maybe a small crisis before a
big crisis just know it's not fine-tune
the crisis to you because we don't have
too much time just you have any
questions please keep them as short and
identify yourselves before you ask if
they have any questions from the
audience I don't see any question so if
I see one over there sorry
I my name seem as a couch I have a
question but I'm British
my life is French we have family offs in
France and UK we travel between the two
and for our senior euro is great going
to France at least that we don't have to
do any any exchange however the two
families respectively do not travel
outside their countries principally if I
want to be passionate about the Euro how
do I sell that to them how do I tell
them that is great thing for them
because you know most of the advances
were given for the individuals when in
terms of travel and not having to change
currencies well maybe to come back on
shows some points of course if you do
not travel this is one of the obvious
advantages of Europe nowadays I would
say to shop abroad you do not even need
to travel if you do purchases in
Internet shops still having a euro
provides you with a much broader choice
of options where you can shop but first
we must remember that Europe was
primarily not introduced for the ease of
travel one of the reasons why euro was
introduced and why it was preceded with
exchange rate mechanism was to ensure
price stability within EU a single
market and to avoid the scenarios of
competitive devaluations of the
currencies and that's indeed what we had
consistently seen prior to Euro that
number of countries were consistently
having rounds of div elation and
correspondingly high inflation in those
countries
so what euro has helped to bring was a
price stability and that's a benefit for
for all Europeans in those countries
even if they are not travelling abroad
at all thank you
anyone else wanna comment on well
obviously
I'm traveling once a year in each of the
19 countries of the euro area because I
have now 1500 people in Frankfurt but I
have also 2,000 people working for TSN
so directly force in Frankfurt in the 19
countries and obviously to be able to
travel with the single currency
you've the symbol is very very strong
not only it's very practical but I think
the symbol is really very very strong
it's a store value so if you trust the
Euro you trust Europe which means that
well if you lose trust in the Euro you
may trust your place on its that's why
it's so immensely important that the
management of the currency is well done
by a strong institution like the the ECB
but as a citizen on the supervisor in
your area yes it's it's very important
to have a single currency and I'm now my
objective is that this single currency
is valued the same when it is in any of
the banks in the nineteen country that
investor equally sure that they will get
one year all back when they put one euro
in one these of these banks thank you do
you have other questions from the
audience we have one over there
so my name is Michelle maja and I
represent the category of German
interest and I'm Burton for mr. Trichet
and vice-president you spoke about
democratic accountability of the euro
could you comment further on that
I only spoke of democratic
accountability but also on reinforcing
governance as you might have heard on
accountability my intuition is that we
should have a format of the European
Parliament with the MPs that are elected
by members country members of the euro
area and when you have a particularly
acute problem for instance when a
particular country is challenging the
wisdom of what is proposed by the
Commission and accepted or decided by
the council applying the governance the
rules of the euro area governance it
seems to me that it would be legitimate
to ask the last word to be given by the
Parliament because in terms of
democratic legitimacy nothing is better
in all our democracy than those
representatives that are elected by
universal polling and I know that it's
very difficult I know that it would of
course call for a new treaty or an
amendment of the treaty but it seems to
me that we cannot go I refer to the
crisis we had in permanent happenings at
the level of the European Council where
heads of state and government are
discussing without anybody knowing what
would be the final solution problem
between say to oversimplify Greece on
the one hand and the institutions of
Europe on the other hand that cannot be
the permanent regime you must have a
legitimate democratic way to solve such
problems to the extent that what happens
in one particular country member of the
yeah it has a man's influence on all
others and as we could experience of
course in the crisis well yes maybe to
add some of the points on democratic
accountability well first and foremost
we see it also as mr. Desai said it as
accountability towards European
Parliament and the European Commission
has consistently proposed to put number
of intergovernmental solutions and
intergovernmental bodies which were
created during the crisis because of
course it was quicker to create some in
inter-governmental way to put them in a
community in European Union framework
and thus making them democratically
accountable to European Parliament it
concerns for example our proposal on a
development of European Stability
Mechanism or potentially European
monetary fund well forget the term
European Monetary Fund I think it's off
table because ECB is objecting saying
it's only one monetary institution it's
ECB in eurozone and we accept it but
nevertheless but it must be said that
progress in that area is actually a
relatively slow we do not see much
enthusiasm of member states of now
moving from the intergovernmental format
including for ESM into community
framework we also proposed for example
or to enhance accountability potentially
turning Eurogroup into formal council
formation we proposed so-called double
headed you
finance minister which would be at the
same time chair of Euro group and
vice-president of European Commission or
member of European Commission also this
proposal currently is not having much
traction then of course it's also worth
noting that the form of democratic
accountability in any case exists
because whenever finance ministers also
come to the Eurogroup meetings there
each democratically accountable to their
Parliament's and of course there will be
always a right balance and enlight
structures to be found because it's
clear if member states have decided to
join the same currency they have to
follow the same set of rules
otherwise it undermines the trust and it
undermines the functionality of eurozone
and for that there needs to be some
pooled serenity shared sovereignty and
some pooled decision-making in as this
fiscal and macroeconomic area so there
is a delicate balance to be found I mean
if I can just ask a follow-up question
give me that most of the important
decisions if not all with respect to the
crisis of with respect to the economic
issues are taking at the Eurogroup which
is this kind of informal council
formation how do you think you could
convince countries and finance ministers
to cede their power and hand it over to
a more you know to a parliament or to a
more community framework I mean what
would be the incentive for countries in
that case yeah well on this as I said
European Commission already put forward
the corresponding proposals to move them
into community law actually that was
something which was also initially
agreed by member states themselves that
they are creating number of structures
during the crisis in intergovernmental
format for a sake of speed of
decision-making
obviously it's quicker this way but that
at the end of the day it should be
brought in a community framework member
states are not questioning it now the
question is at which pace we are moving
and currently indeed space is slower
than European Commission would wish for
thank you is there anyone I think we
need a German on the panel
I'm not a German so I can't speak for
Germany but I'm sorry if you want to get
the Germans to sign up to a more
integrated eurozone with Edith the
Deposit Insurance Scheme with the
eurozone budget with with a bigger
resolution fund and more elements of a
transfer Union the last thing you want
to do is give the European Parliament
more power sorry let's be realistic
Dalal would it was a great pragmatist he
would have understood that the you if
the European Parliament does not provide
the money through the Europe through the
EU budget it should not be the key
decision-maker in eurozone bailouts if
national parliaments like the Bundestag
of voting money for bailouts they have
to be involved if you want to get the
Germans to accept elements of a transfer
Union has to be at least initially
intergovernmental it's not true of
course a child know that we certainly
have their very big difficulty but that
being said in the long run and we are
speaking of historic construction there
are a number of things which were not
accepted in the short run or in even
medium run and have been accepted in the
long run I don't see how you could in
the I would say long future that we are
also designing not having a European
Parliament that would have more towers
and of course it calls also for other
decisions in other domain but we have a
parliament which is elected by universal
polling it is very important we have to
recognize that and I fully accept of
course that it hurts some of our country
member country including the Bundestag
which by the way is the crucial element
in the exemplary representative
democracy that is Germany and it is very
very important to see to which extent
there is a difference between the power
and influence of the executive branches
in the various country it is I would say
mainly in Germany that the final say in
all cases is the say of the European of
the German Bundestag that's absolutely
clear charges right but again we are
reflecting on longer terms we have maybe
time for one more quick question because
we're running out of time I don't know
if there is one if I don't see one if No
maybe I'll just add maybe one over there
quick yes--that's d Lodovico from
ambrosia ditalion think-tank a question
for President Trichet and the
vice-president on browser skis as in any
good adviser anniversary we tend also to
look outward and forward and not only
backward and inward so the question is
could you share your thoughts about what
are you envisaging about the future role
of the euro in the world of the the
currency the currency of the Europe in
the world if I may just one word I know
that the Commission is reflecting a lot
and the fact that we are all here is is
illustrating this determination of the
Commission I would say practically from
the beginning we became the number two
currency in the world from the beginning
and it was not a done deal ex ante a lot
of observers were saying no it will it
won't be a credible currency when you
are merging said together the the DM the
Escudo and the peseta you cannot have a
credible currency we had promised a
credible currency we deliver the product
credible currency and we will number two
from the very beginning we maintain the
position of number two in most criteria
far away and far above the yen which is
until now the third international
currency so the success of the euro from
that standpoint is absolutely clear
crystal clear in this domain you do not
want to hurt markets too violently and
abruptly say that we become the
equivalent of the dollar overnight then
it would push the euro extremely high on
exchange market and then of course for
Europe it wouldn't be good because we
would lose competitiveness on the old
market old trade market so it has to be
done progressively I would say the start
has been extremely good and it will go
on but you have to replace that in the
context of the alignment be becoming
progressively not
but progressively part of the
international monetary system and my
long-term vision is a system which would
be largely tri-polar with the dollar zu
ho more or less with the same influence
and the renminbi and we will see from
that point where we go but again I would
say from that standpoint I consider
radio has a big big success
in the international markets and maybe
something on the roll of the euro well
yes indeed so now we are celebrating 20
years of Euro and despite its young age
euro is already successful currency it's
a world second largest reserve currency
it's widely used in trade some 60
countries across the world are pegging
or adjusting their currencies one way or
another to Euro so and as I said it has
brought price stability in Europe itself
so it's a successful currency so what we
now see for the future
first we need to complete the work on
deepening of economic and monetary union
we discussed the main elements already
we must remember that euro was envisaged
as a currency for the EU so we expect
actually more and more EU countries to
join euro and we expect as mr. tishell
just said also to strengthen the
international role of the euro and next
week European Commission will come
forward as a communication on how to
strengthen the international role of the
euro I think you mean this week right
this week not next week it's sorry
indeed it's this week that we have to
bring our discussion to an end I'd like
to join you thanking our speakers today
for this discussion
and just for the journalist mr.
Dabrowski is going to do press point
upstairs right now in the coffee break
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you